[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
in this video we're breaking down
episode 4 of the boys
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yet then i highly recommend that you
check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we'll be doing breakdowns on the show
week by week
and you definitely don't want to miss
any of them now without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so episode 4 opens with women
discussing what their idea of love is
this is revealed to be auditions for the
deep's wife but it actually thematically
ties into the episode itself
with pretty much all of the characters
defining what love is for themselves
and then realizing that they aren't
really able to have it
frenchie sees it as caring for someone
in a moment that they feel lost
and because of this he makes a move on
kimako but he gets rejected
hughie and annie almost get together but
because of war they're unable to
mother's milk discusses it in a story
about his father
billy through his wife and homelander
well
well homelander goes on a pretty crazy
arc now he's quickly becoming my
favorite character
for all the wrong reasons he has a real
change of heart in this episode
and up until this point he's pretty much
been the most adored person on the
planet
everyone seems to love him and because
of this his ego's gone completely out of
control
homelander felt so much love towards
himself that the only person that he
ever ended up loving
was of course himself things change
though with stormfront becoming the face
of the seven
and slowly he watches as all this love
is stripped away
and turned into hate he pretty much
relies on public admiration in order to
feel good about himself
but throughout he realizes how shallow
that truly is and in the end
comes the conclusion that he doesn't
need anyone to love him at all
not even himself pretty much every
character in the episode tries to hold
on to the thing that they love dearly
and because of this they almost feel
like they've lost at the end
except for homelander who decides to let
it go and thus he can move on
we'll get into it in a bit but after the
auditions we cut to frenchie
who's mashed off his face and he makes a
move on kimiko
who's still reeling from the death of
her brother in the wake of last week we
learned that kenji has been blamed for
the murders carried out by stormfront
and the super terror villains are
further used as a weapon by vort
in order to draw the public's attention
away from the compound v
reveal now we learn in this episode that
stormfront is actually a racist soup
that was alive in the 70s and after she
murdered an innocent black man
she faded into obscurity stormfront has
changed her identity
and is now masquerading as this
completely different person
fit with a new origin story however
she's still the same person underneath
and holds the same prejudices which is
why she murdered 59 people
mostly made up of minorities when going
after kenji
stormfront gets more of a platform in
this episode and she very much
represents how anger
and pointing the finger at the wrong
group of people can lead to a unified
army of followers
that will just carry out your agenda
believing that they're taking back power
when really all they're doing is giving
it to you i don't know if that's a
political metaphor
but seeing her make the american
population hate supervillains
who as we know are all made up of
minorities definitely feels like it's
touching on a lot of social commentary
the seven themselves are thought to be
very much a symbol of whiteness
and in the episode it's brought up that
there's no real minorities in the group
except for a train who spoiler alert
gets kicked out of it
even before this reveal now we discover
that 92 percent of heroes are caucasian
but as we know far more exists than that
except for
they carry the label of villain instead
of hero
i could just be reading into that and
how it's portrayed but i do think that
the show is actually setting up a
reunion of the old seven
as there have been several teasers
towards them stormfront or rather
liberty was a member
and we know that eagerly archer also was
as well
soldier boy has also been name-dropped
and as he's confirmed for season 3
it does seem like things are shaping up
to go that way
now how she's managed to live this long
without aging
actually ties into compound v itself
though it's not been expressly said in
the show
as far as the source material is
concerned it's hinted that homelander
might actually be in his 60s
and this is because the drug makes
people age slower
thus it might even be possible that
stormfront is actually a lot more
similar to a comic counterpart than
initially thought
in our first three episode breakdown we
talked about how the real one was one of
the bad guys in world war ii
there's already been mention of
frederick vort and we do know that he
worked for germany during the war
attempting to create the aryan superman
ayakash is jewish
and who knows war may have experimented
on her during the war
and this is where she gained her
abilities when vort fled germany
he could have taken her with him and hid
her in plain sight
it is possible that because the
character doesn't really age that she
traveled through the airs
taking on new identities whilst pushing
her agendas
through the guise of social change
liberty herself operated in an area
that still has monuments of the
confederate flag so it may be possible
that she was
actually leading a lot of racial
tensions at the time well that's just a
theory for now
but i think they're slowly linking the
character back to the comics which
i wasn't expecting at all when cash was
first cast
now she really goes to blows with
homelander in this episode who's
arguably at his lowest point ever
after killing stilwell he still craves
their love because
they very much had a weird oedipus
complex to their relationship
he wants his love more than anything but
of course can't have it and all there is
is this illusion of it
thus he's been meeting with a soup
called doppelganger who's able to
shapeshift
i thought it was absolutely hilarious
when this was revealed to be some fat
old dude
and yeah you don't always get mystique
he feeds homelander breast milk
and comforts him as we see the world
turn against the character
together they watch taxi driver which i
actually think plays heavily into the
show itself
taxi driver is basically about a crazy
guy that turns into a vigilante one day
and goes to an apartment block killing a
lot of people
though we as the audience have seen his
personal life and know that he's not all
there
the citizens of the story don't and at
the end of the movie
he's seen as a hero even though we know
this isn't the case
this is of course very similar to
stormfront who has self-destroyed an
apartment block
and then got labeled as a savior it's
also reflected in homelander who breaks
at the end of the episode
and kills a version of himself this
mirrored standoff reminded me a lot of
the senior taxi driver
in which robert de niro says you you
talking to me
and uh that was terrible and i liked how
there was some symmetry with the
characters seeing a version of himself
and then deciding to end it much like
how robb's character did in the film
elsewhere we watch his billy learns the
location of his wife
from his new cia contact after the death
of reina and the attack carried out by
stormfront
her conscience has made her realize that
keeping things secret
has led to her having a lot of blood on
her hands she has a recurring dream in
which all those killed by supes
sit there watching her waiting for her
to act she's had enough of this in
action
and hands over the details of not only
liberty but also the location of the
boat facility where becker and ryan are
held
annie hughie and mother's milk go off on
a road trip together
and this is spurred on by homelander
threatening her in an elevator
and get out here for not killing huey
homelander almost puts his hand directly
through her abdomen
he decides not to murder her but she
still fears for a life
now this is because we learned that one
of her greatest fears is that homelander
will kill her
and because of this she says she walks
around the tower with a constant knot in
her stomach
homelander putting his hand into her
abdomen in an almost twisting fashion
though not intentional for the character
clearly has been done by the writers to
mirror this knot
to show that one of her greatest fears
almost came to fruition
i thought it was a really subtle line
that had a great payoff and also seeing
black noir trying to get to the bottom
of where billy butcher is
was absolutely hilarious i'm still not
sure whether they're gonna tie things in
with his comic origins
but there is a little line that hints
that they're not now in the comics
homelander says that black noir is the
member of the seven that he's known the
longest
but in this season we've learned that
it's maeve so
though it could tie in and i don't want
to spoil the twist just yet
it does seem like they're actually going
in a completely different direction
now one of the things that i found
interesting in this episode is that
hughie and annie
really connect under a bridge and billy
and his wife connect above one
symbolically bridges mean either hiding
from someone or getting over it
so annie hiding under this shows the
former with billy and his wife showing
the latter
could be reaching there just just
something i picked up on
and let's be honest this entire video is
just one big reach anyway
now both yui and billy get to reconnect
with the ones that they love
but because of their situations with
fort we know that things aren't going to
be easy
both the women are pretty much
controlled by the corporation
and they live in very vulnerable
positions where if either way to leave
their lives would be compromised this is
why both annie and becker decide to stay
where they are at the end
and there are a lot of similarities
between their journeys
now someone who gets to leave the 7 or
rather is forced out
is a train the character realizes that
he's getting replaced when he spots
shockwave in the tower
who you may remember raced against him
in the first season
a train clearly loved being in the 7 but
he's unable to have
it because of his heart problems again
this ties into the theme of the episode
and i think he's definitely gonna become
a wild card as we get into the season
we then cut to the road trip and get
another billy joel song
so far joel has pretty much been the
singer of the season
and this scene marks the third time that
one of his songs has been played
initially it was pressure and then we
heard you're only human
this time we get we didn't start the
fire and it actually holds a lot of
meaning to the ark that
huey has gone on now joel actually got
the idea for this song
when he was in a recording studio with
sean lennon who just turned 21.
lennon remarked that it was a terrible
time to be 21 and joel who was 40 at the
time
said when he was 21 he thought that it
was awful as well
lennon said that it was nowhere near as
bad as it was for him these days
and that nothing really happened when
joel was 21 which made joel realize that
a lot of things
such as the korean war the swiss canal
crisis
and more have been lost to time and thus
he started putting together a track to
show that there's always been a lot of
big events in history
that have kept the fire burning on the
world as we know
huey thinks that he's having the worst
time ever and that things have never
been this bad
however this song reminds him that
things are always awful
and yeah that's a nice positive message
i think that makes him
not feel alone anymore i guess now this
is cemented when huey meets a woman
connected to liberty
and two discovers that superpowered
people have always been corrupt
on the road we actually learn a lot
about annie and also mother's milk
the former says that her mother had her
on a restricted diet
because she was a pushy parent that
wanted her to get into the seven
on the other hand her father used to
actually listen to what she wanted
and allowed her to have treats showing
that he actually cared about what her
goals were
whereas a mother only cared about her
own mirroring this
mother's milk's dad used to take him to
an ice cream store
where he'd abuse their free sample
policy and would taste
every single flavor mother's milk eh
more like
father's dairy am i right no
no but the character does say that even
though he was embarrassed at the time
he'd do anything to be able to go back
once more and this ties into the theme
and he too wants to save a person her in
a car crash but she must let this go
in order to remain incognito now another
great part of the episode
is that we actually get to see billy and
becker back together
they spend the night together on the
bridge and we see how much she wants to
leave
but how the danger that thought pose is
what's holding her back
becca threatened to kill herself in
front of ryan if homelander didn't free
billy
and this is how he survived the ending
of the first season they get it on that
night
whilst huey does with annie and though
they promise to be together
we see how the hard light of day can
change a lot of things
it seems like love but until you get an
ed sheeran tattoo
it's obviously not that serious now one
of the big shockers in the episode
comes during an in-depth interview with
homelander and maeve on tv
he outsmave and shows that he also knows
about the girlfriend
that she's been keeping quiet it shows
that homelander wants either people in
the seven that he can control through
fear
or he doesn't want them at all at the
end of the episode
i think it's setting up the fact that he
will be taking the group out one by one
and clearly has no qualms about
threatening maeve
any a train or storm front looks like
it's gonna just be him in black noir by
the end of it
which you know what i'm not even that
mad at now
he might not even need to kill
stormfront as we see kemiko
almost attack her at a rally frenchie
stops there
but i really do think that she will get
revenge down the line
shortly after we learn the truth about
stormfront and also discover that
because the person who accused her was
black
that she simply wasn't believed vote
paid her off
and we still aren't really sure of what
happened between her last appearance in
1979
up until today she's pretty much used
the internet as a weapon to turn the
public against homelander
and it very much shows how social media
can quickly change public opinion
using memes she's launched a campaign to
take him down all while supplanting
herself as the new leader of the seven
in this position she'll be able to
influence the public even more
and turn the world into her vision as i
said earlier i've done a complete 180 on
thinking that they aren't making her in
line with the comics
and even her lightning bolt earring
symbol is similar to the iconography
that hitler used to use
becca meets billy at the bridge but she
suspects that he'll try and get rid of
ryan
belly confirms this because he knows
that vort won't let him get away
becca doesn't want to abandon him to be
raised by the corporation
as this will inevitably make him become
another homelander
and thus she decides to stay to make
matters worse
black noir has been up all night with
the researcher drinking red bull
and they've found butcher at the
compound and he calls things off for
huey
and though she lets him down gently it's
clear that she realizes how dangerous
them being together
is it's at this point that we realize
that the talking heads throughout have
been the deep holding auditions for his
wife
and though he almost goes back to his
old ways he's talked into taking things
into a new direction
to win favor back with the seven i love
how he says
i thought i got to choose and all he
gets back is you do
and you're choosing cassandra it's a
subtle line to show that he doesn't
really have a choice at all
and he's pretty much gonna be told what
to do until his image is fixed
the deep loves the seven and what comes
with it
and in order to do it he's gonna have to
let go of the man that he was
and of course his his true love
goodbye the episode ends with homelander
meeting doppelganger again
who transforms into him in order to try
and please him
it's the weirdest scene in the sea
scratch that you know what it's the
weirdest seed in a comic book property
ever
and homelander sees this version of
himself and calls it pathetic he says he
doesn't need anyone to love him
he doesn't need anyone and then kills it
which is when we cut to black
now what's going on well clearly he's
off the leash
and over the last couple of episodes
he's been slowly drifting away from fort
claiming that they need him
more than he needs them i think he will
actually go fully rogue
and may even try to take ryan in order
to raise him on his own
at this moment it seems like that's the
only thing he cares about
and he's getting to the point where i'm
expecting to just see him lose it
obviously there's going to be a lot of
things coming down the line but yeah
what a strange episode but but also a
great one
now as always i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the first three entries
which is going to be linked at the end
also giving away a free copy of the
christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment
below the win is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat who's on the
discord server linked in the description
or at heavyspoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i've been definition and breast milk
you made my day
[Music]
you